So the future didn't turn out the way
you want
it to.
But don't worry.
You always land on your face to say.
What is this thing?
Oh, I forgot how bad it looks.
I've seen worse.
It's a world destroying weapon.
It's closing.
You, but it belongs to me.
That's how you got permission to engage.
I got this idea.
What is he talking about?
Talking about this one.
Oh, I forgot how bad it looks.
I've seen worse.
Where? You don't want to know.
Okay.
What the hell is this thing?
It's. It's called the Scarab.
It was given to my dad when I was a kid.
It's some kind of a world destroying
weapon.
Oh, that's what this is.
What?
And did you know what was going to happen
to my brother
when you stuck him with this world
destroying thing?
No, I swear to you,
I had no idea this would happen.
I mean, my father said
it can't be activated by just any person.
It has to choose you.
So I'm guessing it's chosen you.
So you went in to get a jobs
and all you brought back was a hamburger.
Okay.
I don't think it's a burger
you haven't looked at.
She's not on it.
Hello? Yeah, Yeah.
No, I wanna get that.
Yeah, okay. Okay. One, like I.
You guys are so childish.
What the hell is that?
Oh, who?
That?
The new Tamagotchi.
How did you get her to do that?
I don't know.
Hum. Um,
I think I would go
back.
Oh, yeah, I know.
And then I was like, Oh.
This probably off the time.
Sure.
Okay.
Oh. Oh.
Oh. I tried telling you.
Okay, guys, I need to go find Jenny
because she's.
She's going to know
how to get this thing out of me.
Where are my shoes?
Come on.
Not the 80 fours.
These were my favorite shoes.
Okay. Okay. Kylie, what happened?
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I think I caught a bus.
And how
one flew into orbit.
Flew into orbit?
I don't know. So I need to find Paul.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
There's a bunch of new blue
Beetle trailer footage
and Easter eggs for the upcoming
DC movies, including more of the Scarabs
and the new version of the Justice League
characters like Batman and Superman.
Some of the others they just announced
like Green Lantern Booster Gold.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're also doing a giveaway for tickets
for the movie
because it's coming out next week.
all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know where you want
Blue Beetle to show.
Up next after this,
there are reports that he's going to be
in that Booster Gold TV show,
but we don't know exactly
when that's going to premiere
probably the next couple of years,
I'm supposed to see the movie next week,
so I'll post my review on Wednesday
as soon as they let us in.
My full breakdown.
Easter Eggs Post-Credits Scene videos.
Bigger videos like that
we'll post later next week after the movie
actually comes out in theaters.
so be sure to go see it
as soon as possible.
Do not wait to go see it.
the first big thing here is them
explaining Ted Kord in the movie.
They just clarified in the recent trailers
that Bruna is playing Jenny Cord,
the daughter of Ted Court early.
They just called her Jenny.
They didn't say that she was a cord.
when the events of the movie pick up,
it seems like she's gone on to work
for his company, Court Industries.
But it's being controlled currently
by Ted Court's evil sister, Victoria Cord,
played by Susan Sarandon.
they don't say
exactly what happened to him,
but they make it sound like he's either
disappeared or he's died before the events
or they believe that he died,
even if he's still alive out there.
they'll probably explain
what really happened to him
in some post-credits scene
where he actually shows up really alive.
Like he's still alive out there somewhere
and will show up in future DC movies
and TV shows.
that's kind of the way
things happened in the comics.
I'll explain his backstory in a second,
because the transition between
the characters is meant to be similar
to the way
they transition to different versions
of the Blue Beetle in this movie.
the other change that they made is that
I think that Victoria Court in the movie
is actually supposed to be Ted Court's
mother, so it'd be Jenny's grandmother
in the comics Victoria Court is evil
but she's Ted Court sister.
but she's meant to be the reason
why Jaime Ray is in this movie in the DCU
becomes the blue Beetle
but doesn't give him the scarab
knowing that it would choose him
with a giant big belly burger.
Easter egg level.
The big belly burgers they have in
all the DC TV shows like the Flash Arrow,
all those shows, and now in the DCU,
They did a bunch of funny
in-universe ads for Big Belly Burger
during the DC TV shows.
they're actually doing campaigns
in real life.
I think there are places
that are selling burgers that are themed
after the Blue Beetle, like they look
like blue burgers like this, like scarabs.
the idea though
she's become a scientist at court industry
she's a chip off the old block
but she's fundamentally trying
to carry on the legacy of her father
as the blue beetle with all of his tech
like he has his own version of the back,
basically, which he takes them to
That's where we get all the Batman
references in the Batman jokes.
This is Bruna
talking about Ted Cord's daughter.
Good with your advice.
But do not open it.
Jenny is responsible
for turning him into Blue Veto.
It's two.
Sorry about Hymie and his family.
How he got chosen by this year
to be the next leader.
But I don't know what was going to happen
to my brother
when you stuck him with this world
destroying thing.
Oh, my gosh.
How did you do that?
I have no idea how
Jenny is trying to honor her dad's legacy.
No way.
Ted Court was Blue Beetle.
My dad was never able to unlock the skirt,
so instead he built his own tech. Wow.
Least
I am Jenny.
And the writers are trying
to protect Hymie and the scarab.
when they tease, there's
a lot of places to take her character.
They have a lot of plans for her
character,
what they might do is they might turn her
into one of the other scarabs.
Like, there are a bunch of other scarabs.
There's a yellow beetle, there's a blood
beetle that's red, there's black beetle,
there's a bunch of others
legacy,
though
they don't totally explain what happened
to Ted Court in the trailers,
but in the comics,
their way of explaining him
not being around when Jaime Reyes becomes
the Blue Beetle is during
the Infinite Crisis storyline.
that was meant to be DC's big follow up
event to Crisis on Infinite Earths,
which had happened years earlier
in their way of
sort of cleaning up their old continuity
by destroying a bunch of their universes
like a bunch of their older
versions of the characters.
the idea was that Alexander Luther
survived the Anti-Monitor destruction
of his universe when he was going around
destroying universes,
trying to bring the wider multiverse back
and during the countdown
to infinite crises
like the lead up to that
storyline, Ted Cord discovers Maxwell
Lord plans to control and monitor
superheroes using Checkmate.
he then seemingly kills him,
which is why he's not around.
When the scare finds its way to him,
Ray is in.
It basically
plays out the way you see in the trailers
where it bonds with his spine.
the difference in the comics, though,
is that Booster gold was actually present
for a lot of these scenes
you see here where he's with his family
and they're discovering
what's happened to his body
I don't think the new version of Booster
Gold is actually in the movie.
But if he is in the movie,
it might be in some kind of post-credits
scene teaser later.
Blue Beetle went on to work with the other
Justice League heroes, including Guy
Gardner's Green Lantern,
who was just cast.
Nathan Fillion is now Guy Gardner Green
Lantern in the new Justice League movies.
He's going to appear in Superman Legacy
first
that's why they announced his character,
because they were announcing
a bunch of big Justice League characters
appearing in Superman Legacy.
they worked together
to take down the Brother Ice satellite
who had become sentient
and create the Omak cyborgs
and were using them
to take over the world.
Supposedly, they're going to introduce
Brother AI during this movie.
So I think that's
what this array is here in this scene.
and what they might have done.
They might have just turned the car park
still in here into a version of his comic
book character in also one of the comics
from the comics created by Brother.
I Like he'll be the stand in for the comic
book.
Oh, Max, once his armor evolves
later in the movie, like you
see it in the movie, it's sort of evolves
the same way.
The blue beetles armor evolves.
end, what they might do
is they might just say that in the DCU,
Victoria Kord is the one who creates
the Brother I satellite in
wants to use the blue Beetle scarab
to make it even more powerful.
there are two post-credits
scenes, Dave confirms.
The early theory is that one of them
will just be a funny moment.
Paying off a joke
from earlier in the movie.
But the other Post-Credits scene
will tease the rich and the other scarabs
like the black scarab, green scarab,
yellow scarab, the blood scarab.
the idea is that the reach use
the scarabs is a backdoor way
to take over civilizations
because of what happened in their history
with the Green Lantern Corps.
So thousands of years ago,
they got into a war with the Green Lantern
Corps, the Owens,
who said that they couldn't go around
taking over other civilizations anymore.
They basically tried to stop them.
So instead of taking over plants
the old fashioned way,
they had to start sending scarabs
to planets who would then bond with hosts.
They would think that it was a blessing,
but really
the scarab
would take over their body in their mind
and they would take over the planet
for the rich.
Setting it up for invasion.
So I think the end of the movie, they'll
just tease the coming of the reach.
The actor recently talked about his future
in the DCU.
James Gunn also confirmed a lot
of what he was talking about,
saying that he would be back
in the upcoming DC movies and TV shows
have had the pleasure
of getting to speak with Mr.
James Gunn and the whole DC fan.
Oh, And if it does, well,
we'll get to open more doors
for more blue beetles
and not even just for the
people up here, but there's
a whole thing set up, so.
When he says they have a whole thing
set up, quote unquote.
He's talking about the other scarabs,
the reach
the Blue Beetle,
working with Booster Gold,
the other new Justice League characters
and crossovers on top of the sequel movie
that they set up,
even though based on the box office
tracking right now, I'm not expecting them
to do Blue Beetle too.
what they might do
is they might just incorporate
that whole reach in the other Scarabs
storyline into the other crossovers
that he appears in, like into that Booster
Gold TV series.
the actor talked about his love of Batman
in real life.
If he does crossover with the new version
of Batman though, from Batman Brave
in the Bold, that wouldn't be too
like the next Justice League movie.
Look, there are some characters
that he'll cross over with way sooner
in some of the characters,
you only see him crossing over with
like really big Justice League movies.
I don't expect to see him
crossover in Superman.
Like to see like James Gunn just announced
a whole bunch of characters,
like really big ones
that he's introducing during that.
So I think is already really full
of crossover characters.
they didn't say what the next big Justice
League
movie is actually going to be about.
But James Gunn did tease
this Kingdom come image when he said
he's, quote unquote, making plans.
I don't think that he's literally
doing an adaptation of kingdom
Come for the next Justice League.
There might be some inspiration taken
from that version of the Justice
League, though.
let me know in the comments.
Where do you want to see
the Blue Beetle character
crossover with in the DC movies in the DC
TV shows the next couple of years?
My review should post on Wednesday,
so look out for that.
My post-credits scene videos
for Easter Eggs breakdown videos.
Like I said, we'll post later in the week
after the movie actually comes out,
so be sure to go see it
as soon as possible.
click here for that new Green Lantern
Justice League teaser for Superman Legacy
the James Gunn just announced.
And click here for my new Loki Season
two trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!